[Music]
hi everyone now welcome to the new
episode of architecting with google
cloud
today we are going to see that as an
organization goes on an application
modernization journey and especially
using cloud native solutions what are
the challenges and the journey that it
has to
undertake especially if the organization
has got applications that have been
there for a while plus combine that with
their newer applications and provide
this
in a consistent fashion via platform
build on
containerization technologies i am ramen
irani i work as a developer advocate at
google cloud and today i'm pleased to
welcome jeff turnum who's a principal
architect at hcl software welcome jeff
to the show
thank you very much for having me yeah
i'm jeff turnum i've been in software
development now for just about 25 years
the last four and a half of those have
been with hcl
i work on what's called the platform
team we work on
cross-platform cross-portfolio
innovations
and in particular for the last couple
years we've been really focused in on
containerization and kubernetes and our
cloud native journey
thanks jeff so let's get started and
tell us a little bit more about hcl and
the sophie product
sure so hcl has a large and growing
catalog of software we offer software to
our users and business partners that
covers a wide range of areas things like
devops tools security tools digital
solutions customer experience and
marketing
and we probably have a lot of the same
challenges that other software providers
do and that is how do you deal with all
of the various platforms that that your
users want to run on how do you handle
licensing and upgrades in a consistent
way how do you do delivery of software
in a consistent way
so we've been looking to solve these
challenges and a couple years ago we
started to see that cloud native
technologies we're starting to provide a
really nice answer for a lot of those
questions
and so we use that opportunity to take a
fresh look
and we've been on a cloud-native journey
evolving our software portfolio since
then
and i work on what's called sophie short
for solution factory it's basically our
face
to our users and our business partners
of all of our cloud native efforts it's
a catalog that users can browse they can
see all of our cloud native software
and the most exciting part of it is
perhaps anything in the catalog you can
click on and deploy and try out in a few
minutes and then you can also take it
away to your your
cloud provider of choice and install it
there so yeah that's our focus and
that's what we've been working on for
the last couple years that's interesting
so uh you know if we could uh sort of uh
uh go a little bit deeper and maybe you
could tell us about how you sort of went
about your journey and then you know the
role of gcp uh you know towards that
right so getting started on a cloud
native journey is challenging especially
if you're like we were starting from a
position of not being anywhere on that
journey so we had to skill up some teams
we had to understand the landscape of
tools we had to do lots of prototyping
i personally did a tremendous amount of
watching tech talks to see how other
companies that are running their
business on kubernetes are doing these
types of things
and so once we got over that hurdle we
started looking across cloud vendors to
see
you know how are we going to start
building some of these things what
platforms are we going to use and we
pretty quickly realized that gcp and gke
offered a really nice balance of
usability versus full function
and so
all of our development teams that get
started when they try out gcp and in
particular gke the the kubernetes parts
um they get up to speed very quickly
because uh gke makes it very easy to do
things in clusters create clusters
manage clusters and so on and then for
our operations teams that actually run
these things in production
they can get all the capability they
need to go do observability and
monitoring and other things
so for us
we actually did try out several cloud
vendors and we landed back on gcp and
gke because of the ease of use and
because of the power
one of the things we really find
appealing about gcp and gke and this
might sound surprising is the
documentation
so most challenges we have are just the
search away we usually land directly in
the uh gcp dock
and particularly for for
my team what we really like is that
everything that is documented in the uh
as actions you can take in the ui to
implement something usually right there
beside it is documentation on how you
use gcloud or some other tool to
automate that exact same thing and so
for us trying to run a fully deployed
and robust application in kubernetes
automation is key and so we really like
the fact that api's automation is built
in from the ground up um in everything
we do and then also i would also say
um and we weren't expecting this to be
um as as as much of a deciding factor as
it is we really appreciate the gcp
support so opening support tickets and
actually most of our support tickets are
questions we'll ask questions how do we
do this how do we do this particular
thing in kubernetes uh what's what's the
best practice and opening those types of
tickets is easy and getting responses
quickly is also easy so
um yeah across the board we're very
happy with with gcp and gke
thank you jeff for the feedback and it's
it's good to see how our existing online
content helped your team
get up to speed and also the
documentation and support
along with of course the whole
manageability of gke and out of the box
monitoring so i think it's time now to
go to an interesting uh you know part
which is to look at your architecture
and how you sort of brought this into
reality so let's jump into the
architecture
sure so just as a reminder so sophie
short for solution factory provides to
our end users and business partners a
catalog of our software they can browse
it they can learn about everything in
the catalog and then they can deploy it
and they actually have a couple options
when it comes to deployment they can
basically take away a package and go
install it into their own cloud native
environment or what we find gets the
most excitement is anything in our
catalog you can click on and try out in
a few minutes and the way that's done is
we actually do a real
kubernetes deploy when the user says
they want to deploy something so
our architecture works like this when
our users first come to our website they
are hitting a gcp load balancer
that load balancer is protected with
cloud armor so malicious traffic you
know won't even get to our application
uh
typically
so when a traffic does get to our
application then it's hitting what we
call the sophie cluster
which is where our sophie application
runs the application that provides the
catalog and all of the the the web
experience that the users get
so as users browse around the catalog
they're interacting with our our sophie
application and then when a user wants
to deploy something quickly and try it
out in a few minutes
they basically press a deploy button and
that kicks off under the covers a helm
install that will go install what
they've selected out to what we call our
sandbox cluster
this cluster is a very large cluster
that that has all kinds of uh various
node pools in it we have windows node
tools because some of our workloads are
windows we have custom node pools for
some particular workloads that need to
run a certain way and then we have the
generic linux node pools and you know
hundreds of nodes
and so when a user
installs their application gets
installed in this cluster and they get
back uh
network endpoints that they can connect
to a few minutes later typically so
they'll be able to log into our software
try it out and so on
um and
across all of this is all of the images
that are getting pulled all the
container images are getting pulled in
these environments are getting pulled
from
google google's container registry gcr
and for when we want to deliver software
to our end users
we actually use another image registry
for that we're using a harbor very
popular open source image registry and
we run that in yet another gke cluster
and then across all of these
environments and i should say this
environment pictured here
is just one of our environments it's our
production environment we obviously have
internal environments that that for our
dev teams for test teams for performance
for security for staging so we basically
clones of this uh throughout our work
all of these environments are protected
with various levels of security but also
observability and monitoring and
alerting for when things go wrong
and we also have backup done with valero
that
backs up to google storage and we can
restore in the case of emergency very
easily that way so yeah that's basically
the the architecture in a nutshell
thanks jeff for taking us step by step
through the architecture and it's
amazing to see that you know beneath all
that complexity the experience that
you've given to the users is a single
click to deploy the applications what
i'd like to do as you are talking
through
to the architecture is uh specifically
you know
from a gke perspective which forms
really the core of your platform uh
could you tell us specifically a few
things around gk and what particularly
was well suited to your applications
plus i'd like to touch a little bit onto
the whole security aspect with cloud
armor and how that service has also
helped you
sure so yeah when i think about gke the
term that comes to mind is progressive
disclosure and i mean that in the nicest
possible way so when you
as a new user when you try out uh gke
creating your first cluster is just a
few clicks there's a whole bunch of
stuff
beneath the surface there for when you
need it
and so for for us in particular our
operations team needs to understand
at the most detailed level possible
what's going on in our clusters whether
that's the sophie cluster that runs our
application or the sandbox cluster that
runs all of the user deployed
applications or whether that's harbor or
image registry and so what we really
appreciate is that observability and
monitoring and logging is just
built into everything we didn't have to
do anything special to enable it it's
just there waiting for us to run
monitoring and logging queries and get
all that data so we built up an entire
suite around those capabilities where we
have alerts which will kick off when
certain events happen things like a node
going bad or
pods going unhealthy things like that so
we have all kinds of stuff built around
that and i'd say across
you know to your security comment i'd
say across the board our general
experience is when we need to use a gcp
service it's quite straightforward so
you know taking the example of cloud
armor
um i think uh it probably took us an
hour maybe to install cloud armor uh for
our initial prototypes um and that most
of that was just reading the docs to
understand what it was doing the actual
enablement of it with the load balancer
and the appropriate back end in our
cluster was was really really
straightforward
and then we also had to do some testing
to make sure you know um
malicious payloads were getting blocked
and things like that but yeah the the
documentation the defaults they were all
set and tuned very well for our use case
and then when we do need to make changes
as we mentioned earlier it's all in the
docs and and very easy to understand so
i think that's really why we why we like
using gcp so much as the services are
there when we need them and the
capability is there even if it's behind
a very nice
easy to use
facade there's a whole bunch of
interesting stuff waiting to be
discovered
the other interesting thing i'd like to
ask is that as you build this platform
i'm sure you know there were
certain points in time where you had to
make certain architectural decisions or
certain challenges that came your way to
make that platform a reality could you
throw some lights on a few challenges
that you faced and sort of how you had
to overcome it as you went along
sure so yeah because we started from uh
from
ground zero i'm sure we've encountered a
lot of the same challenges that any
other
organization would encounter especially
ones that are starting from an existing
portfolio of software and trying to
modernize it or make it cloud native
so you know we've had to do quite a lot
of internal education and enablement on
these topics and one thing we learned
early on just to get specific one thing
we learned early on was that
it's very easy
to skip over some really important parts
of configuration when you're deploying
kubernetes applications so one example
anyone who's deployed kubernetes apps in
production will probably
understand this quite well but when you
deploy a workload something that's got a
pod
the way you set those
its resource limits basically how much
cpu and memory it can use can have a
dramatic impact on performance um and
and it's it's just two little lines
usually or four little lines in yaml but
it can have a tremendous impact on on
how your application actually runs and
performs and we saw this so we had some
of our uh
existing software that got put into a
cloud-native form factor containerized
packaged it all looked good but when we
ran it
it was actually underperforming it was
actually performing much more slowly
than it would if you deployed onto a vm
or or elsewhere when we looked into it
the root cause was cpu throttling
and so
um the the interesting part of that is
the fix for that is usually very simple
it's tweaking those few lines of yaml
but the trick is knowing what values to
put in in the first place how do i know
how much cpu my workload should request
how do i know what its limit is going to
be
and so we
again opened up a support ticket with
gcp to basically ask that question how
do we set these values how what's the
best practice for for doing this uh the
support folks hooked us up with some
google experts
we got on a call had a chat about this
topic and they basically turned us on to
the power of vertical pod auto scaler
which when you run that tool in
recommendation mode it effectively
answers the question for you it tells
you here's what your cpu setting should
be here's what your memory settings
should be it's basically watching your
application and and and giving you
recommendations so um we've rolled that
out across the the org and we're
now focused on making sure that as our
products change that we keep up to date
with that so we don't want a product
change to introduce something that
requires more cpu and our configuration
doesn't change so it's the question is
how do you monitor how do you make sure
make sure you're continuously uh
checking and improving that so one thing
that we're looking at for the upcoming
year
is if you think back to our architecture
every time a user deploys something to
what we call our sandbox
it deploys to one big cluster that big
sandbox cluster i mentioned and that's
got us it's got us
a lot of benefits and it's got us a long
way
the one nice thing about it is it's one
cluster for our ops team to manage and
maintain and monitor and so when
something goes wrong it's very easy to
know oh there's the cluster that we need
to go fix
and so on
however there are some use cases that we
really want to enable for our end users
and business partners that we can't
really do uh or we can't do it robustly
with this current architecture one of
them is
in addition to just letting users have
access to their endpoints the you know
the the product endpoints that they can
connect to in in the deployed
application we actually want some of our
users to be able to get cube admin
rights to be able to use cubecontrol to
get into their cluster and start poking
around and do things like check on the
status of pods maybe delete some pods
change configuration things like that
that's not something we've been willing
to entertain with a large cluster a
large shared cluster because because of
the security implications and all of the
testing that would be required
so what we're looking at is moving to a
model where
when a user says they want to try out
some of our software we don't just
deploy their application we actually
spin up dynamically
a cluster purpose built for that
workload so it would be sized correctly
it would have the right sort of node
pools you know if it's a windows
workload or it has some windows in there
it would have a windows no pool if not
it wouldn't
and basically spin these things up
quickly on demand
and so we want to move to that sort of
architecture or at least
experiment and make sure that that makes
sense
and basically get to a model of much
more dynamic much more
provisioned infrastructure coming and
going quickly we also want to take a
much closer look at gke autopilot which
lets teams like us
abstract away even further from the
concept of nodes and really just focus
on our pods and workloads
and so we'll be experimenting with that
as well so you have many other examples
but across the board we're always
looking for ways to improve our
architecture so the final thing i wanted
to ask you and i'm just curious about
this is that for a platform of this type
you know there are different
stakeholders in the organization so
could you throw some light on what it
means to be uh you know successful or
how do you measure success for a
platform like this
great question and this is something
we've been uh building up over time over
the last four years that we've been
working on this
and so
the way we see it observability and
improvement happens at various different
various different levels so down at the
technical level uh which we've been
talking about up till now you know for
that you obviously need observability
logging monitoring you need someone
looking at those uh alerts and those
those logs and taking action
so that's that's i'm almost the easy
part because a lot of that uh logging
and monitoring functionality is built in
what's a little more challenging
especially for large organizations with
thousands of developers and you know
dozens and dozens of software products
is how do you move your whole
organization to become cloud native both
in culture and how they deliver things
and so what we've had to do in hcl
is not just hope and pray that
it happens organically we actually at
the executive level have tracking of
what we call our cloud native maturities
we have a cloud-native maturity model
that we've built up um it's basic it's
it's built on a lot of the best
practices that you can go out and find
other people talking about with cloud
native but it's basically a scorecard
and it talks about things like how do
you build your containers both for
security but also for robustness and
logging and and things like that how do
you package your containers into a
kubernetes application effectively um
how do you ensure that the application's
monitorable um how do you ensure
resilience and things like that
so all of our products actually get
scored on that cloud native maturity
model and where there's deficiencies or
gaps that becomes part of the product's
roadmap and so this as i said it's
tracked at the executive level it's not
left as a it's something that each
product manager needs to make sure they
they
carve out time for and so i think in a
large organization that's really the way
it has to be done if your end goal is a
consistent
cloud-native
uh evolution across all of your products
i will mention one other thing just
because it's top of mind we're actually
doing this right now
we're really looking now at a level of
testing that we've never done before i
know other organizations are far ahead
of us on this but we're really looking
at chaos engineering
is a way to make sure that our
applications are resilient against all
kinds of things that can and do go wrong
in production
so we are now setting up
full chaos engineering environments
where we can run all of our products we
can inject we're actually using litmus
chaos open source project for this where
we eject all kinds of bad things
into our cluster things like network
slowdowns cpu memory throttling nodes
going bad pods getting restarted all
kinds of this types of of chaos and
making sure our products can handle it
and recover and in in the best case have
no impact to user experience during
these events yeah it's a it's a constant
journey and if you ask me you know four
or five years from now i'm sure we'll
still be on this journey we'll be
thinking about new things and new ways
to optimize and improve so
it's never ending uh so thank you once
again for sharing uh you know your
journey as well as you know
giving us an overview of how you built
out sophie and particularly the whole uh
you know journey towards cloud native
and ensuring uh you know that along with
gcp you're able to build out this
platform thanks for sharing all your
inputs along the way uh it was a
pleasure to have you on this show thank
you so much jeff yes thanks thanks so
much for having me thank you for joining
us for this episode of architecting with
google cloud if you've enjoyed this
episode please
like and subscribe to this channel thank
you for joining us today
[Music]
you